hi Twihards The Twilight Saga gave us
plenty of drama on screen but that's
nothing compared to the drama off screen
these are the behind-the-scenes secrets
that will change the way you view the
franchise with Stephenie Meyer releasing
midnight Sun in August 2020 well finally
get see here Edward Cullen side of the
story but what about Robert Pattinson
side of the story or Kristen Stewart
Anna Kendrick and the rest of the cast
shocking opinions discover the dark
truth about filming the Twilight Saga
movies and what it was really like
behind the scenes this great I don't
know why I can't handle that
I can't handle it Anna Kendrick revealed
that the Twilight set wasn't always a
happy place in an interview with Vanity
Fair in June 2020 the actor admitted she
was so miserable she wanted to
annihilate the rest of the cast but
that's not because she hated them it was
actually because she was so cold and
miserable filming in Portland Oregon she
recalls her shoes being completely
soaked through and that made her want to
take out her co-stars but it was also a
bonding experience like going through
some trauma event such as surviving a
hostage situation that's pretty intense
right calm down Anna and I just remember
being so cool and miserable we couldn't
imagine anyone but Taylor Lautner
playing Jacob black but it turns out the
new moon director Chris Weitz could
imagine someone else playing the
werewolf and that someone was Michael
köppen in fact Michael came very close
to replacing Taylor for the second movie
are you as outraged as we are the
director wasn't sure Taylor could bulk
up enough to play the beefed up Jacob
Chris Weitz explained he had nothing
against Taylor personally it was just
about the storyline fortunately Tammy
went on an intense weight training and
diet regimen and kept the part
speaking of casting twilight author
Stephenie Meyer had a wish list for the
actors she wanted to play her precious
characters and guess what
it wasn't the eventual lineup she
originally wanted Henry Cavill to play
Edward :
but by the time summit entertainment
option Twilight in 2007 Henry was too
old he was 24 and Stephenie refused to
consider anyone over 21
so to champion Henry for Carlisle and
wanted Tom Sturridge for Edward Tom just
happens to be Robert Pattinson BFF
awkward as for Bella Swan Stephanie
wanted Emily Browning and she wanted
Taylor Posey for Jacob you have no idea
how tight I'm bound we can't help but
wonder if Stephenie Meyer's still wishes
Tom Sturridge got the part after all Tom
might not have bad-mouthed the franchise
quite as much as Robert Pattinson has
done over the years what's the worst
thing Rob said we reckon it's when he
said he hated Edward :
Stephanie adores that character so it
must have hurt to hear that the leading
man described Edward as the most
ridiculous person Rob didn't stop there
he revealed the more he read the script
the more he hated this guy ouch he's
trying to hide it all the time which is
annoying at least Rob didn't have a
creepy doll stand-in for him
did you know they used the Bela doll for
the Breaking Dawn Part 1 birth scene the
fact that the doll was totally creepy
was deliberate according to John
rosengrant the film's animatronics and
special make-up effects supervisor he
said he was shocked that the director
Bill Condon actually wanted the doll to
look so real it was creepy
however they did have to cut a lot of
the scene in order to keep a pg-13
rating until that baby is born we're not
gonna see anything beyond what Bella
could see Rachelle Lefevre was seriously
annoyed about being replaced as Victoria
by Bryce Dallas Howard in Eclipse the
studio said the recasting was down to
scheduling conflicts but the actor
herself said she was stunned by Sumit's
decision as she was fully committed to
it but did you know there's a further
twist to this tale Bryce Dallas Howard
was originally approached for the role
for the first movie she turned it down
at that point because she thought it was
too small apart talked about rubbing
salt in that wound you know visually you
have no control and you don't know what
the end result is gonna be certain
actors had to suffer for their art well
film a twilight like Nikki Reed well
more specifically her hair suffered it
fell out because of the excessive
bleaching she went through to be
rosalie so Nikki had to wear a wig for
New Moon she revealed it took a massive
36 hours initially to make her blond and
then every other day she was bleaching
her head and her skin it's no wonder she
switched to a wig and I looked at my wig
and when I took it off and I was so
happy to get that thing off The Twilight
Saga made Kristen Stewart mega famous
but what if she hadn't got the role
could you imagine Jennifer Lawrence's
Bella well she actually auditioned for
the part but missed out j-law had no
hard feelings she didn't realize the
franchise would become such a big deal
and given that she went on to star in
the hugely successful Hunger Games we're
not surprised she doesn't mind there
were also rumors that Vanessa Hudgens
auditioned for the part of Lea
Clearwater I'm really sorry about your
father if you're here to torture Jacob
some more feel free to leave actors are
pretty polite about the creators of the
stories they tell
but Robert Pattinson has said he thinks
Stephenie Meyer is mad he said he
thought stephanie was convinced she was
Bella that's a pretty interesting theory
Rob explain please the actor went on to
reveal he had that opinion because
Stephanie said the story was based on a
dream she had about this amazing guy
then she went and wrote a book about it
she's completely mad and she's in love
with her own fictional creation
speaking of Stephenie Meyer did you spot
her cameo appearances the author and her
laptop appeared in the first Twilight
film during the diner scene and then she
also appeared as a guest at Bella and
Edwards wedding in Breaking Dawn Part 1
she sat with screenwriter Melissa
Rosenberg and producer Wyck Godfrey some
cast members actually auditions for
different parts to the ones they ended
up playing take Jackson Rathborne for
example the actor originally auditioned
for Edward Cullen but he ended up
playing Jasper the same goes for Kellan
Lutz his team also sent him out for
Edward but he ended up playing Emmett
after the original choice for that role
fell through we can't help but wonder
how the other actors felt about Robert
we wouldn't blame them if they felt a
bit jealous
don't antagonize her she the strongest
one in the house please have you ever
wondered what the hardest part of
playing a vampire is well according to
many of the actors it's the eye where
apparently the contact lenses were
unbearable Robert said he was
uncomfortable for the entire time
because of them and Kellan Lutz also
said that wearing context used to
seriously bug him on set however Kellan
understood that they saved a lot of time
and effort that's because the movie
makers wouldn't have to
use special effects for their vampire
eyes and Breaking Dawn the actors had a
hard time even seeing through their
colored contacts I loved everyone's
love-hate relationship with the wig in
the contact oh my god there's so much
hate there it's not just the contact
lenses that were a problem the hair
pieces also caused some issues remember
jacob's long hair in the first movie
Taylor Lautner hated the wig he had to
wear the actor joked that his wig was a
very important co-star after his
character got shorter hair he certainly
didn't miss the wig much in fact he
joked that there was a hatred between
the two of them the wig did not like him
and he did not like it not fond memories
he added who knew a wig could cause such
an effect Kristen Stewart's first day on
the Twilight set was memorable for all
the wrong reasons that's because she
nearly passed out they were filming the
ballet studio scene Krista remembers
going to open the door for the first
time and try to rev herself up to such
an insane degree that she actually
almost passed out not only that in
excruciating pain shot out of her head
and then they called action and she had
to get it together she'd never had that
experience before on a movie and she
felt it was kind of fitting that it
happened at the start of her twilight
experience what is sign for things to
come it's actually one of the coolest
things I've ever done that wasn't the
only scary moment in Kristen's
experience on set when filming New Moon
director Chris Weitz wanted Kristen to
be weighted down for the drowning scene
she was also concerned about the deep
water so wedge tried it himself
he realized how terrifying it was to
have weights in your pockets when you're
12 feet underwater so he led Kristen's
stay up at the top of the pool he lauded
Rob for having the guts to go so deep
Rob had already done underwater work on
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire so
it wasn't surprising that he was more
comfortable with it director Bill Condon
had to tone down Edward and Bella's
highly anticipated wedding night scene
the original version meant Breaking Dawn
Part 1 received an R rating they also
had to ensure the bird scene wasn't too
intense for the film to be given a pg-13
rating Kristen Stewart spoke about her
shock at the controversial scene in the
movie she revealed it was so weird it
didn't even feel like they were doing a
twilight film the actor find it all very
surreal I don't think they use any of
those shots
Breaking Dawn Part two also had to cut
some pretty important things from the
final version we're talking about the
terrifying Renesmee doll it was so
freaky it was nicknamed chick as me we
can all breathe a sigh of relief that
the filmmakers opted to use CGI instead
of the mechanical doll producer Wyck
Godfrey called chick has made one of the
most grotesque animatronic babies ever
to not be seen on film during the
promotion of the movie Kristen Stewart
admitted that the dose scared her
because it's so closely resembled Chucky
we're with you on that Kristen if you're
Bella you're looking at going I don't
want that thing Robert Pattinson had
another swipe at the franchise when
talking about promotional duties he
revealed the Twilight poster photo shoot
took two days when he and his co-stars
asked why it was taking so long
the suits explained for the toys and the
Burger King hats and although Rob
understood it's difficult for movies to
make money he still found it weird being
a part of that kind of representing
something you don't particularly like
after he made that admission Rob added
he really head-butted it yep you sure
did Robert sometimes actors have to use
little tricks to change their appearance
and Taylor Lautner did just that to make
himself seem taller compared to Kristen
Stewart the actor had to wear lifts in
his shoe to exaggerate the difference
between Jacob and Bella in New Moon
wardrobe stylist Tish monoghan also
revealed that they tailored all of the
t-shirts Taylor worked to make it seem
like he was busting out of them to be
fair the actor put in hard work as well
to alter his appearance like eating
4,000 calories a day and doing strength
training exercises that's commitment to
a role right there
hello biceps you know anabolic steroids
are really bad for you when 11 year old
McKenzie joined the cast to play
Renesmee in Breaking Dawn Part two she
made some extra cash robert revealed
that the cast's were really not polite
to each other by the time they got to
this final movie so they'd have to tone
it down when McKenzie was around she had
a little swear jar and Rob reckons she
made 850 bucks or something as well as
keeping their language in check having
the young star on set really brought
something paternal out in Rob and
Kristen was especially protective said
director Bill Condon oh you guys he just
loved being around kids which
behind-the-scenes secrets shocked you
the most has it changed your opinion
about your favorite characters and
actors in the franchise remember to hit
that subscribe button to be the first to
know when we
load more videos like this thanks for
watching
you